bien bonjour à tous alors je m'appelle
Guillaume Morano effectivement je suis
professeur de philosophie et je m'occupe
dans mes recherches de la technique en
général et de la techno science en
particulier
et ce sujet donc je suis venu vous
entretenir aujourd'hui
alors pour commencer entrer un peu dans
le bain quelques phénomènes
en 1994 des chercheurs de l'Université
de Cambridge sont parvenus à fusionner
des cellules d'embryon de chèvre et de
moutons et de faire porter le résultat à
une mère de substitution qui a donné
naissance à une chimère chèvre mouton
40 ans plus tard les progrès fulgurants
dans le domaine du génie génétique nous
permettent d'envisager la possibilité
d'une optimisation fonctionnelle des
espèces existantes une recréation
technique des espèces disparues et
pourquoi pas une fabrication d'animaux
imaginaires
selon certains tenants du génie
génétique les limites donne notre
pouvoir de recréation de la vie ne
serait plus celle que de notre
imagination collective
ma foi il y a trop à faire à force
d'étonnement peut-être sommes-nous
saturés de stupéfaction ou peut-être
avons-nous cessé de nous étonner plus
simplement parce que tout cela
fonctionne
mais en un sens peu importe
quand la finalité de cette intervention
que je vous propose c'est de réveiller
en nous justement la faculté de nous
étonner de ces prodiges ne serait-ce que
pour nous permettre de penser le monde
dans lequel il nous donne peu à peu
d'habiter
alors pour celui qui se laisse un peu
inquiéter
par les chèvres moutons les lapins
fluorescents je crois que c'est
phénomène soulèvent au moins deux
questions ce sont celles que nous sommes
posées avec mon ami Pierre Dulot dans
notre ouvrage La luminotore
première question comment s'est prodiges
sont-ils seulement possibles
ou comment faut-il se rapporter au réel
pour y introduire de telles distorsion
deuxième question
qu'est-ce qu'elle signifie pour nous
comment comprendre si vous préférez du
point de vue des cultures humaines cette
possibilité d'une réécriture technique
de la réalité
alors et si on commençait par la
première question
quoi que si c'est prodige de la
technologie sont possibles
c'est parce que la techno science
intervient à une échelle de la réalité
au sein de laquelle toute frontière
symbolique
pour que les nanotechnologies nous
proposent par exemple la fabrication
de matériaux aux propriétés absolument
inédites
il faut qu'elle intervienne à l'échelle
atomique de la matière pour en
reconfigurer les interactions
pour que le génie génétique puisse nous
proposer ces chimères en série il faut
pareillement qu'il intervienne à
l'échelle moléculaire du code génétique
dire que des frontières existent
effectivement entre les êtres et qui
interdit à n'importe quoi de se
reproduire avec n'importe quoi vous
connaissez l'expression les chats ne
font pas des chiens
mais les chèvres et les moutons ne font
pas non plus de chèvres moutons et si un
lapin devait croiser une méduse il
l'enfant très pas le lapin fluorescent
d'Edouard hockey
évidemment ces frontières qui semblent
exister symbolisme à l'échelle
moléculaire du code génétique dès lors
qu'il est possible d'isoler d'identifier
et d'en recombiner les séquences
pour que le cerveau puisse commander à
la machine comme dans le cadre du singe
télékinésique et des prothèses
commandées par la pensée ou pour que la
machine puisse commander au cerveau
comme dans le cadre des expériences des
rats télécommandées
il faut pareillement que leur activité
soit réduite à un ensemble de signaux
électrochimiques qui rendent possible
leur interaction
donc on le comprend à cet échelle de la
réalité électrochimique atomique
moléculaire
on ne rencontre plus des choses ou des
êtres des gens ou des espèces
on ne trouve plus que des réactions et
des interactions
des processus et des états des flux des
codes des signaux soit un ensemble de
phénomènes
intégralement manipulables en droit
sinon en fait
alors on comprend que pour la techno
science
les choses et les êtres les gens et les
espèces n'apparaissent plus que comme
des trompes l'oeils en fait de simples
illusions produites par un effet de
perspective et qui s'estompe dès lors
que l'on pénètre à l'échelle
microscopique du réel
la techno science ne reconnaît
finalement comme réel que cette
dimension de la réalité qui se prête à
la reprogrammation
c'est dire que pour elle la matière les
organismes vivants et même
l'intelligence humaine n'apparaissent
plus que comme des réservoirs de
configuration possible
un définiment transformable exploitable
productible en un mot parfaitement
substituable
alors on entend souvent parler
aujourd'hui de la sixième extinction de
masse des espèces
et de la disparition progressive des
milieux naturels
on comprend en fait que cette
disparition progressive de la nature
n'est que l'envers d'une médaille dont
l'endroit est la réécriture technique du
réel
ou si vous préférez
nous ne transformons finalement le monde
en désert que pour le repeuplé de nos
propres créatures
tout se passe finalement comme si la
nature et même l'homme produit de la
culture était devenu des régimes
potentiellement obsolètes de présence
alors
penchons-nous maintenant sur la seconde
question
qu'est-ce que tout cela signifie pour
nous
alors je crois qu'une idée s'impose
d'emblée c'est que la technique a cessé
d'être aujourd'hui un ensemble de moyens
plus ou moins efficace à disposition de
la volonté des hommes
qui pourraient décemment concevoir le
deadpote comme un instrument
utile au service du soulagement des
consciences endeuillées
qui pourrait décemment concevoir la
chimère homme animal comme un moyen
comme un autre moralement neutre
techniquement efficace de répondre à la
demande croissante sur le marché des
organes
alors cette conception instrumentale de
la technique qui est encore
majoritairement celle de la bioéthique
je crois que c'est celle qui nous
interdit justement de voir à quel point
la technique contemporaine reconfigure
le cadre entier de notre expérience et
son sens
alors essayons de de creuser
toutes les cultures peut-être qu'il y a
en fait finalement dans cette
métamorphose technique de la réalité
légère en tout cas d'une mutation sans
précédent des conditions culturelles de
la vie humaine
toutes les cultures se sont en effet
construites à partir de polarité
fondamentale immuable le ciel et la
terre ces jours des dieux demeure des
hommes au sein de la terre la
distinction entre les espèces animales
ou la distinction entre l'animal et le
végétal la distinction entre l'homme et
l'animal ou la distinction entre l'homme
et la machine l'intérieur et l'extérieur
le vivant et le mort
ce sont ces grandes polarités qui nous
ont permis de faire une expérience
ordonnée du réel autrement dit qu'ils
nous ont permis d'habiter dans un monde
et non un pur chaos ou n'importe quoi
pour être venir n'importe quoi
et sans doute que le travail de toutes
les cultures a été élevé c'est polarités
à la hauteur d'un sens qui soit
assimilable par l'homme
en les encadrant par des rites sans les
représentant dans des symboles en les
élucidant dans des récits ou des mythes
alors ce sont ces grandes polarités qui
symbolisent à l'heure de la réécriture
technique du réel
précisons le génie génétique brouille la
distinction entre les espèces animales
aussi bien que la distinction entre le
végétal et l'animal ou entre l'homme et
l'animal qui peut dire si la chèvre
mouton est plus chèvre ou mouton si la
chimère est davantage animal cumaines
les techniques de conservation au
laboratoire par aliments abolissent la
frontière de l'intérieur et de
l'extérieur brain ex
de même qu'elles abolissent la frontière
du vivant et du mort
qui peut dire du cerveau de porc des
capitaux dans une cuve s'il est mort ou
vivant
quand à l'homme techniquement augmenté
on le voit il n'est ni homme ni machine
mais présent simultanée et
contradictoire des deux cyborg
alors
on voit bien que
n'assistons pas à travers cette
métamorphose technique du réel a une
rupture qui adviendrait dans l'histoire
des hommes
il s'agit plutôt d'une rupture à l'égard
de l'histoire
quelque chose de l'ordre de la mutation
quelque chose comme une rupture sans
précédent dans la continuité du temps
humain
on pourrait dire une autre manière que
nous d'habitons plus dans un monde mais
dans un immonde pourquoi pas
un état donc dans lequel il n'existe pas
d'autres ordres que celui que la
technique peut produire un état dans
lequel il n'y a pas de forme qui est a
priori plus de valeur qu'une autre un
état dans lequel nous finissons par ne
plus pouvoir dire ce qui est
la technique on le voit ne nous permet
de reprogrammer le réel que dans la
mesure où elle le rend simultanément
impensable
alors
on connaît bien sûr les termes du débat
sur le transhumanisme faut-il être pour
ou contre peut-être que ce débat n'a
finalement aucun sens peut-être que nous
sommes d'ores et déjà les transs humains
soit au sens étymologique du terme ce
maillon permettant de relier l'humanité
telle qu'elle s'est historiquement
constituée de l'humanité intégralement
technicisée du jour d'après
quand on le voit bien
avec cette métamorphose technique de la
réalité nous assistons à l'avènement de
ce qu'on pourrait appeler une altérité
quelque chose qui ne se laisse plus
inscrire dans le cadre de l'histoire
humaine
quelque chose qui ne se laisse plus
penser à partir des catégories
culturelles constituées
et quelque chose qui déborde visiblement
nos capacités éthiques de régulation
alors pour conclure quelques mots encore
peut-être qu'on pourrait repartir de la
question de départ pourquoi faut-il
s'étonner
alors il a répondu pour nous donner à
penser ce qu'il y a de bien
mais pourquoi faut-il se donner à penser
ce qui advient et bien peut-être pour
nous permettre d'entretenir à son égard
un rapport libre
c'est-à-dire que nous assistons à la
métamorphose technique du réel et il
nous faut penser cette métamorphose je
crois si nous ne voulons pas être
emporté par elle ou si nous voulons
avoir la chance encore demain d'habiter
dans un monde dont l'homme soit la
mesure je vous remercie pour votre
attention
[Applaudissements]